o psol seja bem-vinda mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer um
inspirador utilizando uma furadeira
eu vou usar uma furadeira baterias mas
vocês podem usar aquelas com um fio
também a primeira coisa que vocês têm
que fazer é cortar um circo com 20
centímetros de diâmetro
agora se você não puder usar madeira
podem fazer o mesmo utilizando o plano
por isso vocês têm que cortar várias
queimadas quando eu digo várias de 56
camadas da população depois tempo juntá
los todos utilizando uma cola para a
matéria
depois de fazer um um círculo aquino
maio agora o tamanho de circo vai
depender da vossa fora dela
e vocês vão ver mais para frente como é
que isto tem que encaixar e vocês metem
o diâmetro da vossa força da ilha e tem
que cortar um círculo ligeiramente maior
depois colocar esta parte aqui com
enviar vocês têm que fazer alguns cursos
na parte de madeira ou então da
população para que o aluno saia por esta
parte aqui eu tenho que entrar pela
frente pois tem que ser pra um lado e
vai ser por este furo séc
com a tampa da caixa de bolachas vou
fazer uma hélice e é muito importante
por dentro dela seja ligeiramente mais
pequeno diâmetro deve a rafa que você
utilizar e vocês podem usar mais com ela
isso porque a furadeira tem muita força
então permitiu colocar 23 18 84 mesmo
vai depender sempre o tamanho da garrafa
com vocês que utilizarem
primeiro zé luis na pura da ilha vão
precisar de um parafuso com mais ou
menos 14 em tempo de cumprimento
como já não havia à venda então eu
comprei este próximo tal e cortei com o
complemento que eu precisava
é muito importante neste pacto se
explicar em 45 portas que entre reservas
por cento e ficar muito perto aguentar
vai ser mais fraca uma vez que uma vai
atrapalhar o outro fazer o filtro usar
equipes assim do casco da linha max vem
aquela não possível e depois você escola
municipal tasso de outra garrafa que é
ligeiramente mais pequeno e este pacto
vai encaixar no parque grande e eu
pensei fazer desta maneira porque assim
vocês mais para frente podem ter
utilizar esta parte o filtro e colocar
outro
eu acho que aqui vai segurar o filtro na
posição certa
é importante que eu faça alguma força
seja tem que empurrar isso mesmo para
frente para que a boca de uma garrafa
conhecida como boca do outro
está patente portanto que mangueira fica
mais ou menos 34 20 para dentro desta
forma quando vocês pararem de expirar o
lixo não vai ser por fora
foi muita atenção neste o pato vocês têm
que colocar a garrafa do modo que não
toque nas celas única para quem não
gosta desse projeto é que a conexão aqui
entre uma parte garrafa com outra para
isso seja um sinal de usar fita cola mas
se você tiver alguma idéia de como posso
fazer essa conexão sem usar fita cola ou
seja uma maneira prática que não seja
preciso gastar nada
então vocês deixem os comentários que
vai foi esquentado faça outra versão
deste espírito e propôs aos seus o fim e
espero que tenham gostado se você tiver
alguma sugestão de algum projeto é só
deixar nos comentários
e acho que vou optar mesmo do próximo
projeto que estou a fazer
fica evidente